nous allons faire un truc rapide et amusant,
je vais nommer un sport et
tu vas me dire en une phrase
qui est le plus grand joueur de tous les temps,
ok
tennis euh ni jovic
football
Messi basket Jordan
Cricket
telar
poker chéri Brunson
échecs K Kasparov échecs boxe
[Musique]
euh force d'apprentissage
film préféré euh po fiction émission de télévision préférée
enthousiasme Kier dernière application que vous avez utilisée sur
votre téléphone probablement Snapchat
boisson préférée eau boisson alcoolisée préférée
bière ville préférée dans laquelle vous êtes déjà allé un
favori  équipe sportive du Real Madrid debout toute
la nuit ou tôt pour se lever des nuits entières qui
gagne dans un match de boxe d'échecs toi ou
hararo je gagne qui aimerais-tu voir la
boîte d'échecs sinon toi ou hiar choisis deux
personnes dans le monde des échecs karakin et
Peter H le  boîte d'échecs, j'aime ça, j'aime
ça